you bring up a good
uh i thought about um the infrastructure
portion of national security and as you
probably know we have
uh issues with regard to emp hardening
of our
digital infrastructure and to include
our electrical grid
we have cyber vulnerabilities throughout
you know what is your sense now having
kind of looked at this
from the ben's perspective in the role
the government plays in ensuring that
the infrastructure that we have is
capable of
basically taking a licking and keep on
ticking
no this is uh this is a fundamental this
is a fundamental government
responsibility
but but in these cases uh the the
solution to this can
can best be i think can best be pursued
through
public private uh partnerships here it
is in fact
energy companies and business and others
that run these infrastructures that
you're
that you're talking about right here so
there has to be uh there has to be close
uh close relationships and we can't
think of
people in the private sector as vendors
we have to think of them as
partners uh in this uh for our for uh
from the government side
uh and we have to look at how we how we
bring all that together
and and what we're trying to do through
benz you mentioned a couple of key
things here
uh the uh the resilience of our of our
energy grid
this is this is the primary focus of our
energy council a group of members that
has come together to look at how we
how we make sure that we have a more
secure grid uh we you know
the resilience we've got in our
resilience council we're looking at how
we
should be securing supply chains for uh
critical minerals rare earth materials
that are vital for
national um national security and our
economic
viability um you know we're looking at
tech uh
our tech and innovation council we're
looking at uh how we
uh how we secure the the coming 5g
network here so
we can we can prevail in this area we
can drive the
uh the norms and the standards uh that
will guide
this not just in our country but
globally
um so this is i think very very
important there's a real opportunity
here for public-private partnership
in these vital vital areas
[Music]
you